uh welcome back everyone the first
session on Thursday it's my great
pleasure to introduce Shiva Advia he
will be talking about graphone Dynamics
where the Dynamics actually change over
time a very exciting topic please go
ahead Shiva
thank you very much uh Charles can you
hear me
thank you very much for inviting me uh
for this meeting and
the pleasure observing all the talks
this is work with Frank an Adrian who
are in the audience
any questions can be directed to them
but do use the microphone
[Laughter]
this is kind of a
an investigation in progress so the
development I'll report on some have
been proven uh some we think are true
some which are false but I think are
true
the broad idea is I will not go into the
basics of dense graph Theory because I
think everybody's familiar
I want uh so what we wanted was uh
uh a Dynamics on graph on space
uh that came from a discrete system
that's the goal so I'll write the goal
in on the boards that we all his goal is
clear so we all know that you have a
graph on so I'll call it h
is Frank's notation on likes aliens
copper
so I I know I can sort of these are
well-defined functions I can Define some
Dynamics here
what I want is what we wanted was uh in
dense graph we know that there's always
a finite graph
again
but what I want to do is I want to chase
them but uh with all the finite graphs
any sort of system that sort of is
coupled in some way but
so
these typically would weekly converge
for every fixed t but as the graph one
moves as the graph moves at level n
I would like uh
them to replicate the Dynamics you can
think of various things you want to do
with this so
some people turn edges on and off
is age database
yeah as of now everything's up so yeah
but I want a diffusion finally
yeah
look
so this Dynamics in in networks is quite
quite well studied in various forms
in various settings but I think the
dense graph is in its early stages
that's sad to say I think
so you for example in the in if you look
at many applications in biology and even
social networks the network is changing
all the time people are trying to
understand what's going on in the
network
so um
so during the pandemic uh I had the uh
opportunity actually to work with an
agent-based model uh transmitting
infections across so
so I'll discuss three motivation
examples for our study
this is not a motivation but uh so so a
bunch of collaborators of mine built a
simulator from uh this is from a
publishing's model
Ferguson is a person in I think Imperial
he had a simulator for Thailand and he
could simulate Thailand and tell you how
the infection was spread in Thailand
so like that um
so how my collaborators did build the
simulator for Bangalore and uh so I'm
running it uh I think it's taking up
their power and their server but yeah so
you could you could specify many things
like uh like from
from mean incubation time of the disease
to recovery time to how many hospital
stays ICU stays
and how many households there are and so
on so forth and they're all governed by
a by by a sparse graph system
and he allowed the wireless to spread
and you can put a video game and see
what's going on you can check when your
threshold hospital is going to be
reached it how the biology works
but again of course I have populated the
city with 100 000 so that's uh
that's two less Bangles 12 million and
the moment you jack it up more than
three million the simulation installed
so you'll be careful that's a whole new
challenge out there I think
dense graph Theory as well
at the hundred thousand five hundred
thousand level even if
a person like me that's a program it
will run
but anything more than that the
challenges get very very complicated you
have to optimize differently you have to
locally look at it
yeah
my my second motivation was uh
Frank's Frank and remco's early work
on um so what they did was uh they took
the conclusion model uh
they had a random walk on it we had a
certain mixing time
then uh they they did some rewiring
every now and then and they slowed the
walk the walk won't see everybody
so I wanted to understand if uh such a
scheme is possible in the dense review
that was my my initial motivation of
getting into this into this idea
and Aiden and I were before playing with
uh how to sample a
dense graph and the way you sample will
affect what what graphone you see in the
limit and so on so forth so based on
that motivation I wanted to see if
if this could be replicated in the dense
regime
I have some thoughts on that uh I can
discuss that at some point but that also
is not complete so
then uh recently of course there's sort
of uh I would don't have that let me see
foreign
so maybe I'll just show this it's okay
recently they sort of a
being sort of uh connections of graph
forms and in deep Networks
new ad books uh
it's a nice it's a nice nice first step
I think so what they're trying to
understand is trying to provide a at
least uh after I talk to them I
understand from the paper but uh that uh
they're trying to give some sort of
mathematical rigorous meaning to deep
deep learning okay
and they're modeling it as a gradient
descent on graph on space
that's quite nice an idea is quite nice
that's very similar again
uh you look at uh finite graphs
that's like a matrix
so think of it as a gradient flow on RN
squared
and that's n goes to Infinity
if you stick with ghetto and or somebody
else some of the derivative you will get
a gradient flow on the ground
that's quite nice
I think I've explained the world
correctly
that's quite nice that's a nice bit of
work I think
it's beginning I think I think there's
lots of
interesting work available from this
setting as well so there are dynamics
being studied around on graphs and
mathematically and otherwise as well but
very very non-trivial
so coming back to my question that I
wanted to study
um
so uh you can visualize it as any
Dynamics right you take a adoptionary
graph for example
you can do your favorite Dynamics so
you go to Every Edge
turn it off turn it on
in some way uh
or you can mix
it is appearing somewhere it will create
some Dynamics but that Dynamics sustain
the limit
typically in uh in in dense graph Theory
that's little hard to achieve
to get deterministic flow but a
diffusion will be hard to achieve you
don't do something drastic
because you are averaging at the level
of N squared in some sense and then if
you change order n edges you won't see
the limit it'll just go away
the randomness will go away
of course this is a
challenge that describes crane was the
first person Harley Quinn's person
attended
so there's a series of papers uh
they wrote um
but they use the Aldous four Theory to
work with graph ones not
cycling from the graph one at end points
and giving labels they use the
exchangeable array
of course now it's well known that uh
from the Anson and Dacon this is a work
that
the predictions on the graph one space
induce
from from alto Theory exchange everyone
available space but what crane produces
was
processes that are only of locally
bounded variation
that means you can't have diffusions
using that that idea
so when I saw this I saw doctors or
something didn't make sense to us in
some sense
but then it's a very very delicate
result because they're using at every
end
if you're worried about
n n plus one the graph covering in an
almost sure way then you only have to do
this
but if you're only worried about the
structural properties of the graph in a
distribution sense then you don't have
to do this
you only learn about sub graph counts
and other things you don't have to do
this
so you can look at uh your Journeys and
and dromosky Survey I'll attempt a brief
survey
provide supports here
this is the basic Elder Scroll Theory uh
that that you you can think of your
graph as a graph on countable edges
the graph is given you can
any infinite exchangeable array graph is
given by a function of this form where f
is one deterministic function available
so crane used this object uh of course
this is built on diagonals in the
Anson's idea that uh or paper that the
graph on and the exchangeable array
updated by this expression
so the one to one corresponds
you can work with either of them
but if you what happens is that
if you work at the
at the exchangeable array setting
you end up with processes of boundary
variation only
you can't get diffusions because this
somehow there's too much information
you can ensure that is
but it's it's also a matter of taste
right so they can be they could be
potential diffusions here but if you
project down to the graphene space
you'll only get things about variation
the prediction somehow also damages them
so we can't do this
but uh so when Aiden and I discussed
first I mean it's kind of kind of sad
right but also silly but what if I do
the following I take it I take my
classical GNP right that I have right
okay so I don't put p i I just put my
favorite uh
it's probably tsp of T okay
go ahead yeah
microphone
yeah so quick question so going back to
the oldest Hoover thing that you showed
yeah
one more I think
I'll start one more I mean so suppose
now these use and
Etc suppose they're like Brownian
motions or some diffusion then you have
x i JPS so what happens if we do some
keys the key is the the projection right
here
that will give you when you project down
to the graph phone space you will not
get diffusion
you do a calculation
you have an example in our paper we do
exactly what he said
I see if you want an adapter process to
some it'll be two it'll be it'll be
every you know everything about the
whole thing
okay
you're just saying that take uiut and
UJS motion and try the whole thing right
so at the xig level you'll have that but
moment you go to the graphone space as a
projection that projection map will not
give you diffusion
the force should be burning you're right
you can just do a calculation
see this like like stronger said uh or
even simply you take a GNP
but put YT to be some diffusion as a
connection probability so I and J are
connected
with probability uh
YT money
this the height is moving up and down
like a like a burning motion or anything
you want zero one and that's a diffusion
that's a well-defined diffusion all sub
graph cons will diffuse
and it's a nice diffusion so there
should be some way to do this
can't say there's no diffusion on
government space
that's the simplest example you can
think of which should be achievable
so so this example in particular is then
not markovia correct that's right why
not
because
it's a function of F right
that comes up
it's the right questions
so in in Irish Hoover yeah you have your
two variables X the first two variables
which I consider features right and you
have the last variables which give you
the random graph form right and why I
why can't I make my random graph on
Brownian I don't introduce it we as a
user introduce if we as a random graph
right so we have this last you maybe
because they're different random
variables right
okay okay uh I can come back to it it'll
still not work I think
but it's still not work because screen
has shown a theorem that says that when
you predict on the graph one space
you'll only get boundary variation so
wait wait assume so we have an F of U I
don't quite one of your use is actually
the just encodes a random graph that's
right that's right so what if I make F
equal to that U yeah right and then make
you brown in motion then I have exactly
your exam yeah so what do you mean it
doesn't work
so to some extent I'll take what I mean
doesn't work in the sense that I want it
coming from a system of n particles
hey Glory I have a diffusion on in space
that's not that's not my question saying
what this would tell us is that since
this is a random craft one and the
random graph one is sort of an element
of the sigma ultrapy at Infinity your
brown immersion has to somehow sit at
the sigma algebra of infinity
so you will in each observation you will
only see one sample from the Brownian
motion but behind the scene court has a
random graph one which is brown in
motion
I think that's correct uh uh but I I
want to get from I think that's correct
but
I can't take that god-given brand
emotion and repeat this construction
from n to this one I can't do that I
can't have a Dynamics at the end level
that gives me a diffusion
that's what I'm interested in
I'm not interested in obviously giving
you a diffusion on the platform space
that I can give you for sure
any way I want to give it but if I want
to construct from the nth level to the
infinity I can't do it that way foreign
I'm I'm the whole thing is working on
this
I wanted to come from a discrete
Dynamics that's the whole thing so I
want an interesting discrete Dynamic
Dynamics
that passes on and goes to Infinity to a
diffusion on the ground that's whatever
like all of you have said April you can
do either super or yourself and
construct a diffusion on this space by
yourself that's not the construction I
want I want you to come from
[Music]
so thank you
so what would you do so you can see this
idea that look at a fixed t
you look at GNP look at the sub graph
counts right so they will be of uh of
this form the number of copies of f in
GN but the concrete graph
and then as n goes to Infinity they
should surely go to some some graph on H
of T at time T every fixed and that's
the outstranded and this what what are
the key features in this there's an
averaging effect you compare this to the
mean by a concentration and you work
with the law of large numbers of you
statistic to get the result
but it is averaging you lose out the
diffusion part if you start a diffusion
here if you don't do it in a clever
manner
or a drastic man
because what's happening in this is a
lot of average
so let's do our favorite uh stochastic
block model that we have yeah so just
very quick question I know you want to
continue but if you can start with a
Brownian motion you could potentially
discretize it like make a Markov chain
in time yeah so and then do I mean infer
a Dynamics engine okay yeah you should
you could try that what you're then but
you have to show that the sub grass
counts of the induced one gives gives a
brand motion on that one
there may be some challenges there I'll
come to another section that's right
yeah
what what you have to do for that is
what I'll tell you something you can't
do a simple on off mechanism at the GMT
to get a diffusional HD or sometimes
so what I want to do was
I want to do something like this like a
simple let's say stochastic block model
but I want this person to diffuse let's
see something that I want
how do I construct a social network on N
vertices to give me this
for example that I'm after
so I want a sequence G and T
that gives me constraints
and the sequence should not come from YT
okay
comes from YP okay that's easy I think
it's a little sticky but I I want some
interesting Dynamics at the end level
that gives me a diffusion to work
I don't want to take and sample from
this YT and say okay get this right
so what we thought about it and uh so
our first work we decided to do it a
little differently
so if you do like I've said like no you
at at some time you keep some adjective
sometimes from inactive
this averaging will sort of make sure
the deterministic would be the flow will
be deterministically
the randomness not survive because
so you have to do something drastic
so what we did was uh
we went to population genetics uh and uh
we did the following
so you have vertices one up to n
and you give labels for everybody
X1 and uh
x n and at time t
this uh each label is a zero or one so
each XK is a
and then
I all I do is I I do a Moran model on on
this that means that at each time at
rate one an individual in the population
will sample somebody else adopt that
time they can sample themselves as well
that's okay
Rob the attack that's what the first
step is okay
and then I I this is a result from
cochlear genetics I'll come to it in a
second
uh I'll write on the board that's in the
next Slide the graph I do is I connect
everybody of the same time
to connect all once
and connect all zeros okay so it's a
very simple graph
each time only the types are changing
on the type change
the graph reconnects and all type ones
and types
could you also do that with a fixed
probability P hey it's the example I'm
motivating
that the probability one and
this is this this you think of it as
this this will drop one like this
so my question was can you replace the
ones back yeah
I'm just giving an example of how to do
a simple
you know much more
I didn't want to go in the details
immediately
but this is the key ideas once you do
this so then what you do is this is this
point right here is the fraction of ones
so it's x n by n
that's what the graph graph want to look
like at the end level
so now you know if the X N by n converts
to Y with the right Fischer
you're almost there
so then if you just look at the number
of copies of of of a subgraph s in GN
it's just going to be
accented up to a couple of constant I
think I'm in a small error but yeah x n
through Power K divided by n to the K
and N minus that again
once I do that I know from popular
genetics that uh this person right here
is going to go to my right Fischer right
this person right here is also going to
write Fischer right one minus that so
then as n goes to Infinity
I just get going
this graphene this GN
T that I have developed as n goes to
Infinity all the sub graphs will
converge correct subgraphy
I've established that this I can think
of this
as my t f
H is the
so what goes wrong
maybe I
to save my head I'll go say what goes
right with me no no
saying
there's nothing wrong with crane it's
just a predictions
I
so but why can't you apply the currency
up to your example okay so what will
happen is I I'm constructing it at the
end level from the graphs right so I'm
not doing the exchangeable array I'm not
giving you complete information right
my nth level graph is very different
from n plus one level
almost Shook Up
maybe that's a better way that's what
goes wrong with me
so the graph phone is what the graph one
is like this right so then you have two
communities I think
zero and then these guys all are
connected property one and this is the
point right here
foreign
but now once you have it you're on your
way
because uh once you know your subgraph
grounds behave like some polynomial of
your of your type space
that polynomial will converge to the
polynomial on this side
and that will be the polynomial
diffusion
like them go asked you cannot do
anything you want you can change these
people you can make them time dependent
any way you want all you're going to end
up is the way I've set the thing up
I'll always get a polynomial in
typescripts so it's a function of the
type stage
that's how we have rejected
so I play a little trick on you in some
sense I'm not truly creating a graph
Dynamics I'm changing the vertex type
and I'm Brute Force changing lots and
lots of ideas at each time
moment the type changes I'm just zooming
everybody will see something
so each time I'm changing order n Square
edges
formally speaking that's what Saves the
Day
the square root of N squared is n and
you really have to do that right
otherwise you're not going to get any
diffusion
so what happens in the process
so what if you converts to all zeros or
all once
close to all zero yeah it'll this will
have more equilibrium it will just go to
all zeros all at once
yeah let's see the Y will hit zero or
one and then you just left with the
complete graph and then you stay there
that's right that's right there's no
utility that's very cool
thanks
I think this is an important Point
everybody's asked us uh do you have a
non-trivial equilibrium state for this
process do you have an example of a
non-lequilibrium machine
you can get artificial ones but a truly
non-constantly
interesting question I think
I don't think we have a good natural
example we have many artificial examples
that's it that's the black one so now uh
you can do you can you can make it you
can make alpha beta Delta like you want
just the same problem will work same
construction work
so there's a theory to be set up so I've
given you how the sub graph converge if
you want the process to converge you
have to do some you have to set up a
theory correctly
because just I all I showed you a proof
was that the sub graph counts at Time s
goes to sub graph current limit
but I want a diffusion in this space as
a weak convergence of these processes
to set up the theory properly but you're
lucky you're lucky because the sub graph
counts are kind of moments of the
graphics you can work with them
so you'd establish uh so one dimensional
will give you
the the proof that I gave you will give
you the one damage convergence
you have to establish a tightness
critical platform space
and once you do that you have to obtain
process computers
so that's what we did in our first work
um
so uh we have this theorem that um
we have equivalent conditions that
that's graphones going to graph on in in
d0 Infinity among the font space is the
same as these movements converging
is the same as the mean of the moments
coming so it's a sort of a theorem
available for everybody to use right now
you don't need to do any coupling no
exchangeability just look at the sub
graph counts take the moments get on
your way
this credit has set up everybody to use
and you can use it
this was going to be my talk at the
random meeting in before the pandemic so
we were so then uh we start discussing a
little bit more after that so I'll tell
you a bit quickly tell you
so now you can do many more things you
don't have to do one type you can do
multi-type models so the three types and
your different connections each type
they can vary with time
you can do the same constraint that I
did to get his answer right so instead
of uh x n being 0 1 you can say zero one
two
then you have a three by three
then uh
stick with us was working in population
genetics for a long time
the next thing you do is you take M to
infinity and you can do the Flaming view
so you got to continue study limits
sort of
it's not it's not a finite block
stochastic block model tough one anymore
you have a cool graph one that moves
around
in height
but there's still something
disappointing about this whole thing uh
or not disappointing anticlimactic
because everybody is a function of the
time space
in some sense I'm sort of I'm sort of
we're sort of playing a trick
everybody once I give you the type space
the edges are determined in some sense
right
so everybody is a one measurable
function of the
it's truly not that the uh that you'd
like you'd like a model in which
the the edges interact with the vertices
and the vertices interactive edges and
the feedback either way
here moment I give you the vertex types
the graphics determining something
it seems popular afterwards send
randomness
Okay so
so things they are not deterministic
right because Delta Etter and better H
probability you're right but moment I
give you Delta ETA and Gamma and the
types the graph is determined right
but that sort of true first hospital
just true for the standard stochastic
block model as well
next example
it's correct but it's a little bit I'll
tell you an example that I have in mind
and let me maybe my comment will become
more clear what I'm trying to say
for example the the edges don't change
the types the types Move On by
themselves
and given the types the edges are given
but the edges don't interfere with how
the types are moving that's what I meant
by saying that
my comments I'll complete
this is work in progress so from now on
whatever I say may or may not be true in
the last five minutes
supporters will confirm if it's true
so what here what I want to do is uh
what we wanted what we want to do is
that
the vertices will do a water model uh on
on the existing graph at that time okay
so what are the words you're looking at
the time we'll do a water model
and every now and then the edge also
will flip
depending on how the how the vertices so
now what what all we'll have we'll have
our vertex like let me use uh
[Music]
let me use a green for one
let me use orange for zeros correct that
means all my edges will look like
look like let's see there'll be three
types
all my edges will look like at an orange
and an orange
or a green and a green or a Greener
knowledge
that's how my eggs are going to look
right so now what I can do is I can make
my Edge Dynamics
I can make my vertices move in some way
right
so my vertex is what is your move like
water bottle
that one Dynamics happening and my edges
will move depending on how the voltages
are
we'll also flip on and off
the idea is clear
now I can't do what I did before I don't
have Independence I can't average out
the I do SUB graph
I can't compare it to the mean
consideration and get the thing that's
not what happened because I have this
confusion now
is feedback
this model has been studied people have
studied coalescence time of the opinions
on this model I think Reddy Basu and
Alan flyer people on that
but that's on the water model don't
worry about what's happened to the graph
will be something but
so but this is a classical dense graph
regime you'd like to resolve right
so mildly put uh the the idea is very
simple you your number of edges flips is
the same as the total number of types
and the vertex changes are proportional
degree
I think it should be zero one I'm not
sure I know why I put plus minus 1.
because
what are the challenges here so first
challenge is you can't use the old idea
you can't concentrate to the mean
and show you statistics that's gonna be
hard to do because your edges are going
to interact with you vertices
so
if you're just go look at the generator
of this
graph one process
so the end level you can write a
generator down so the it looks CDs but
it's not so it's not so bad see what am
I doing here here let me do them
[Music]
so here I'm just doing the vertex close
okay
so vertex are flipping at rate ETA
so that realize is how the vertex is
flipped from a green to a red or a bread
so let me just copy this down so it's
clear
foreign
what's happening in these two terms is
that
this person right here is measuring the
discordant zeros
or these guys
these guys are measuring the concordance
this one is this one
so is that the number of such edges
which one
I mean
it's just a rate
is generated right it's a generator okay
this is
for your generator you know just take an
infinity and see what happens right
conversion
to converges you're in you're in good
shape you have a measurable you have a
generator on the graph one space
the second order terms then you have a
diffusion and you're on your way
so Aiden did the simulation of this
process you look at the fraction of
zeros in the population
they look quite diffusive they don't
look uh
they're all like a deterministic process
it's a nice diffusion happening that's
clear because the water model is going
to official right
a different community
that's going to be a surprise
the next slide is surprise so maybe I'll
give you a half a second think about
what is happening to the edges right
the edges are flipping depending on how
they have concerned opinions or discard
opinions they're turning off and on with
that right
it's quite cool uh
the total edges are deterministic in
some so that's what the black line says
but each individual color ones are
diffusing
it's not expected after a while you
think about it but
we've got Grandma
you're saying deterministic but it does
seem to be moving that's not a random
curve it's a bounded variation I'm sorry
I take it back that's all I meant I made
one okay I don't think it's a London
sorry it's not diffusion
then uh uh so what you need to do is to
uh this is a this is this proof is
coming up together slowly slowly yeah
lots of stumbling blocks around but
broadly among friends uh the uh you need
a subgraph colored sub graph Theory to
come about because you need to you could
graphs with colors
and shows colored sub graph counts
converge to colored graph forms and
that's not too hot it's available more
or less
we're going to work out the end level
generator
and what happens is that the the trick
is that that
what will happen is you'll have a bunch
of terms multiplied by n okay
in the generator and bunch of nice uh
nice terms here let's put nice which
would be the true generator of the
process
so what you do is
you think of this
as
your manifold on graph phone space
whatever you make sure your graph forms
are all
in the space where this term vanishes
so that's I'll just call it as uh
make it zero and rush into management so
0 and process to Russian demand
so the process will spend very little
time outside his manifold as n gets
larger and larger
and it'll go to the manifold and only
this part will remain yeah
that's what you have to show
if you can show that then you know that
uh it's amazing topology available to
you to show that the process comes out
this is the thing so uh if you have
authors like Adrian who do the work a
few generator he'll calculate
get the whole answer down and then
and then uh
this is something we'd like help on uh
the manifold is the top line
and the bottom is the limiting generator
formally speaking so manifold is
actually like this it's a very nice
graph on set so it's like it's what we
called as tadpole I don't know if that's
a common terminology in craft form
Theory
so we need to understand the following
so I have I have some sub graph that I
have in mind
I pick a Vertex let's say it's green
I'm going to attach another Edge
so what this Edge will do is it will do
one of two possible on the left hand
side let me go here
on the left hand side it will attach
itself
on the left hand side it will attach
itself
I think it'll it'll change its color
to Orange
and then adapt the vertex color and
become green
on the other one it will go attach
itself and become an original
so and this process is what we have we
take a graph a finite graph and do this
process
we need these two counts to be the same
we think this might classify all graph
forms but we don't know that
if it does then your own business
so this is basically saying ignore the
colors if you were to know the sub graph
counts of all the graphs with one Edge
sticking out does that
uniquely identify the graph form that's
your question
yes if that's if that's available to us
then the manual is ready
otherwise it's some artificial condition
it's again Grand claims I think this is
the first example of where the vertices
interact with the edges and and edges
interactive vertices item has been done
ever
we don't use any movement closure or uh
main field approximation Brute Force
competition
I think it's a it's a little class of
models it's very exciting
thank you
for this exciting talk are there any
further questions
so I know of course you've just started
exploring this but for instance in the
graphone case uh the limit graph one
really helped get things that you
couldn't easily get in the prelimit so
here is there a similar it's again a
little anticlimactic I'll tell you what
the limiting platform will be uh you
have a
I mean just just
think a little bit uh
the only two type zeros and ones right
yeah you want to get a stochastic block
model right that's easy to see right
so All That Remains is to estimate
estimate what these guys are these guys
are and what this point is then
so uh
under those SCS that I mentioned before
uh under some uh
some uh some some specific ratios of SC
you'll have a a an equivalent
distribution for the edges and they will
appear here in the alphabet
and the whole thing comes down to what
this guy is going to look like
we believe my tadpole calculation this
will just be a function of the color
about this
and functional is explicit you could
write the function
so it's kind of anticlimactic the
graphone is talking like block all the
hard work
pretty interesting talk so I was
wondering um so this setting is only
working is only work for
um block models where I can characterize
the block structure by finite number of
parameters uh or no we have this Fleming
view process that works quite well
the the filming viewers like I said
about not blocking block so it's very
general you can have height varying as
well you can do very things but it's a
functional type space
so my other sort of um I mean I want to
understand this but um I have some sort
of confusion we have a graph star base
uh and then there's a process on it and
then the evolution is not in terms of
the graph it's in terms some of the
aggregate property of the graph so you
want to understand that rather than
directly understanding the evolution of
the graphs uh I just want to know if
yeah I think that that's all the
interesting examples I think I agree I I
think I don't think technically
let's say I think technically where is
learning
that's about that's a that's a good
thing to understand
um what is uh special about the graph
with us it is sticking out that's what
the manifold is
nth term and Generator the manifold
looks like that
I think that was the same
for countless
[Music]
questions yeah so I guess